do have Alice in the studio with us
Alice the current leader of the junior
girls Alice congratulations a difficult
game against Rose tell us a bit about
this Brewing rivalry issues this is
almost your age as well you know her
well
um no this is actually my first time I'm
playing against her but obviously she's
in really great shape she just like Drew
Carissa yesterday and I think we're
around before
um so this game I thought it was quite
interesting like I thought it wasn't
easy there were some moments especially
like
uh I think this sequence right here when
she started pushing her pawns and you
had to make this big decision of
breaking in the center with D5
after this so
here I wasn't sure whether this was good
I was expecting her to play Queen E5 or
26 after which I calculated and I take
C4 and Knight takes C4 uh I actually
calculated Queen takes E4
um Queen takes Knight takes and here if
Rook takes D7 so I Bishop at five
um I was more concerned about and then I
thought I could play D7 uh rook d8 and
F3 so I mean here she can't take the D7
because like I always have Knight C5 uh
or like afterward takes D7 Bishop takes
Knight C5 or future takes a nice
calculation yeah
um but like what if she takes here and
then it starts running with the King
yeah I thought here I could double Rooks
on the
um D file and I didn't uh I thought like
here I would be able to do like king of
two king of three King G4 but
um I guess she's maybe she has something
yeah Rook A7 B6 things of that nature
but still not easy calculus foreign
she played Queen d8 did this surprise
you this passive approach yeah I was
pretty surprised because I thought Queen
E5 is I mean it should probably be like
around the draw even if I do win upon or
something I should like turn into a work
hunting but after Queen did uh Knight
takes E4 Knight takes C4 Bishop F5 F3 uh
yeah then Queen G5 I was actually very
surprised by this move
um because I I mean it just I didn't
even consider it it doesn't seem like
um the most like natural move because
the queen is just like hanging on G5 so
I thought there has to be something here
um and he found it
C7 and or D6 and yeah after here I
thought it was oh I guess Queen C4
wasn't the best sure because of Queen F7
but yeah it leads to a much better end
game for you so I would say you didn't
lose your advantage by any means
King to h8 and after that you finished
quite nicely
with this attacking sequence
beautiful very nicely calculated all
throughout the game I have to say
it seems like you're in good shape in
this tournament and we were discussing
with Carissa it seems like she believes
that you're her main rival it seems like
probably you believe that she's your
main rival as well right yeah uh
definitely I think he'd just be Iris uh
she did I saw the game it was pretty
convincing
um and I mean uh she's still like she's
only half a point behind me and
um I'll be playing Zoe tomorrow so that
would be a tough game
um but yeah she's I mean she's
definitely my biggest competitor here I
think
um and are you thinking about the end of
the tournament that title or you're just
taking it one game at a time
um I mean obviously I'm like thinking
about it but I don't think that I think
like taking it one game at a time is
just a better approach
um especially because uh if I like don't
do well in the next few games it won't
really matter I guess like how I do
against Carissa exactly because you guys
are meeting later in the tournament
congratulations big victory for you guys
any questions for Alice
Alice congratulations very
straightforward game uh good job I don't
think I have specific questions about
the game but we heard today really cool
tips about what to do when your
tournament is not going your well so far
I feel like this is your year and you
are not experiencing it but I'm
wondering do you have any tips like what
what do you do after you have a bad
tournament or after you have a very bad
loss in a in a tournament
um yeah so I guess like for me uh so I
guess I'll talk from my experience last
year in the tournament because I started
uh I drew the first two games then I
lost the next two
um I mean I guess for me it's like
really important to have this rest day
in between
um so like even if the first half of the
tournament doesn't go too well you can
still uh like uh use the rest day to
just like have a mental reset
um and I think in general if you have a
bad result
um usually what I do is I try to forget
it but also
um it's actually good in some sense that
um whenever I lose a game I feel like I
won't achieve like my goal so it puts
less pressure on myself in like in some
ways
um and just like being able to think
that like have this mentality that uh to
be like just not care as much in some
ways is good because then you won't like
keep thinking about the pressure that
you put on yourself
perfect thank you so much thank you
Alice and here we have